hey uh creme for Rick can we maybe maybe
I can pick what we listen to next you
know will we we've been in the ship for
like three hours now Oh Morty that
entirely depends on whether or not you
have the mental capacity to pick
something I would be willing to listen
to Oh what about logic logic you're not
[ __ ] with logic bro you know I'm
talking about already calmed down of
course I love logic who doesn't like
logic I mean you're gonna be a [ __ ]
idiot if you don't like logic but the
question is what logic are we talking
about here what do you mean well are we
talking about mixtape logic or album
logic what does it matter I mean logic
is logic Morty
it matters very much I don't know Rick I
mean album logic ah Morty I'm sorry I'm
gonna have to decline our request what I
mean crapper Rick are you saying you
don't like logic albums Morty if that's
what I was trying to say I would have
said it don't come at me like a little
punk-ass [ __ ] don't try to come
at me Morty I'm saying that he's got a
plethora of music that varies from mood
to mood Morty okay and I'm saying that
I'm in the mood to turn some [ __ ] up
Morty you know I'm not in the mood for a
message about how I can be whatever I
want or oh you know like equality eating
everybody and all that [ __ ] alright so
when I hear some [ __ ] about titties
throwing stacks on some ass you know
just some good old [ __ ] atl style
club rap Marty geez Rick I mean logic he
turned stuff up on his albums - Rick you
know he turned [ __ ] already shut up
I'm simply implying you know I want some
[ __ ] I could turn up on this ride to
class of our planet and sector g9 ok
right jeez ok so you know so meet me in
the middle Morty you know give me some
of that Bobby Tarantino [ __ ] but tell me
who really bout it
single-person work hard and just wrote a
novel stopping in the movie build
another business why you
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie surprised that
we got some new Rick and Morty so this
is a collab between logic justin roiland
in the Rick and Morty people for the
release of a new mixtape that he's doing
I'll explain what's going on with that
if you're not familiar with him or you
don't listen to his music you'll
probably remember him is the person
who's saying at the party at the end of
the Vindicator zepa sowed which what a
coincidence because they dropped a new
Vindicator story they cut a pixel-art
promo that i attached to the beginning
of this video so I'll explain the logic
promo then I'll explain the new
Vindicator story that they just dropped
but if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we're still waiting to hear more
on season 4 I've already done a video
with some of the cast talking about
what's going on with that so I have
links for that at the end of this but
the whole thing with the logic promo is
that he's just arguing with Morty about
which version of logic is better album
logic mixtape logic the mixtape that
referring to is the original Bobby
Tarantino mixtape from back in 2016 the
new one that they're promoting is just
the second mixtape that's why it's
called Bobby Tarantino to the album
logic that they're referring to is the
album from last year everybody which was
a number one seller so it's patting
themselves on the back and having a
little bit of fun just promoting this
new album it's pretty surprising that
Justin roiland does stuff like this on
the fly he was at a conference talking
about the music of Rick and Morty a
little while ago
they just won two Annie Awards if you
didn't know they won best episode for
pickle Rick which is probably the bigger
award in best writing for the Rick
llantas mix-up and Rick and Morty
[Applause]
obviously thank you - Asifa and the rest
of the nominees sorry I'm all spaced out
right now the rest of the nominees in
the category as well as the rest of the
writers on Rick and Morty obviously Dan
Harmon and Justin roiland are the
creators of the show so I don't think we
need to worry too much about season four
ever happening it just sounds like
they're on some sort of break right now
the new Vindicator story that they just
dropped is set after The Vindicator zepa
so dove season 3 and it's an alternate
reality version of the team coming to
take Rick and Morty on an adventure so
that means that Vance Maxima supernova
Alan rails million ants Crocky BOTS
they're all back it's not all bad though
they were spared having to see their
grown son wear a whistle basically in
Avengers infinity war Infinity Gauntlet
parody with noob new taking fan OSes
place assembling what they call the
infinity balls I'll read the backstory
here but imagine
noop noop becoming the Thanos of the
Rick and Morty multiverse
so remember he's going by the name Boone
he just reversed his name so instead of
noob noob
it's Boone but Boone was once small and
weak and despite all his training he
could never get strong enough big enough
hard enough until he learned about the
infinity balls so many sexual innuendos
here a shortcut to obtaining the power
he desired if only he could get his
hands on some balls so he searched the
multiverse cruising for balls hunting
down balls grabbing balls wherever he
found them if his hands were full he'd
fill his pockets with balls he'd even
put balls in his mouth every crack and
crevice filled with balls
but soon he consumed too much power
played with too many balls now mad with
power Boone will stop at nothing until
he possesses all the infinity balls with
which to bedazzle his infinity glove and
with the glove turned the entire
multiverse into one big ball pit for him
to play in so while they're chasing down
noob noob with the Infinity Gauntlet
they go to a bunch of different season 3
locations like they go back to the Mad
Max planet they go back to visit pickle
Rick they even go back to visit scary
Terry Rick finally starts spamming the
button on the meeseeks box and they take
him down
but if you guys don't read the Rick and
Morty comics they published them pretty
regularly they're supposed to be
non-canonical like they call them the
non-canonical Adventures of Rick and
Morty but the next big story that
they're doing is for a chrome populist
Michael so you can get this on
comiXology or like wherever you buy
comics no worries children animals old
people doesn't matter
I just love killing but if you remember
the end of the Vindicator zepa sowed
supernova crawled away vowing revenge
although as you can see from like the
evil Morty twist during season 3 they're
not super urgent and getting back to
stuff like that so maybe they'll address
it in some offhanded way obviously the
evil Morty storyline is too important
not to do during season 4 but I think
supernova coming back just depends on
the availability of Gillian Jacobs I
don't think we'll see that character
again until the actress can come back to
the TV show but every once in a while
they will include old characters in big
background shots so we'll see but let me
know in the comments which characters
from season three do you want to see
them bring back during season four if
you haven't seen it yet click here for
that season 4 update from the producers
and you can click here for the season 4
a teaser thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]